cheese butter is the delicious gourmet
cheese melt that blends four indulgent
cheeses and seasoned butter i love this
stuff perfect on bread bagel sandwiches
veggies and more you'll get 15 off at
cheesebutter.com pacman the link is down
below
well it happened yesterday just after we
were done filming our thursday show
judge katanji brown jackson has been
confirmed by the senate 53-47
she will be the first black woman on the
supreme court it is a major deal and i'm
not going to spend a lot of time on it
today because we've basically spent the
time already we've talked about her
background we've talked about her
qualifications we've talked about some
of the most disgusting confirmation
hearings that we've seen we've talked
about republicans saying they're not
going to vote for her without really
being able to explain why they're not
going to vote for her
we've talked about all of it and now
she's been confirmed and indeed it was a
53-47 vote it was the 48 democrats the
two independents that caucus with
democrats and the three republicans that
we knew were going to support her
because they said so and that was
senator mitt romney of utah
senator lisa murkowski of alaska and
senator susan collins of maine
no other republican supporting
one of if not the most qualified supreme
court nominees
in as long as i've been covering supreme
court confirmation hearings and when
compared to the nine justices on the
court up until now
as qualified as any of them so
congratulations to her we knew she'd be
confirmed and now the next battle is
going to be
what happens if joe biden gets another
pick
after the midterms
and republicans have taken control of
the senate mitch mcconnell was asked
sometime in the last 24 hours
if you guys take the senate in november
and joe biden gets another pick
would you even hold confirmation
hearings and mitch mcconnell declined to
answer
and it's the same partisan nonsense
we've been talking about for a long time
so that's it for now
the right decision made judge jackson
will soon be justice jackson on the
court
this is also a bit of good news the
department of justice is finally going
to start a formal investigation into
donald trump's 15 boxes of records that
he had secreted away
at mar-a-lago before they were turned
over to the national archives the
washington post reporting the justice
department has begun taking steps to
launch an investigation into former
president donald trump's improper
removal of presidential records to
mar-a-lago some of which were labeled
top secret remember
we couldn't vote for hillary or we
shouldn't because she couldn't be
trusted with secret information trump's
flushing documents incinerating
documents eating documents hiding hiding
away documents at mar-a-lago
the people who spoke on the condition of
anonymity
to discuss an ongoing investigation said
the probe remained in the early stages
it's not yet clear if the justice
department officials have started
reviewing the materials in the boxes or
if they are seeking to interview those
who might have seen them or been
involved in assembling and moving them
the news comes as the department faces
increasing political pressure to
disclose its plans on thursday house
oversight chairwoman carolyn maloney
democrat from new york accused the
justice department of obstructing her
committee's investigation into the 15
boxes of records that trump took with
him so
number one it's about time
number two this is nothing other than
step like 0.1 but at least it's
something and we'll see if and where it
goes anywhere and then again i mean we i
gave you some of these numbers during
previous investigations into trump with
watergate it was
783 days
from the break-in to nixon's resignation
and even then it was only that quick
because nixon resigned
here
we have a situation where trump is no
longer president and we are only in the
early stages
it could be a very very long time iran
contra from reagan announcing the
investigation to the end of the
congressional
investigation was 254 days these things
do take a long time i don't have high
hopes i don't believe trump is going to
do a day in prison you guys already know
i think that but it does look
that you know even in the best cases
where
something provably wrong was done
it still takes a really long time
merrick garland's got to get his act
together and as a reminder joe biden
should have nothing to do with this and
he's not getting involved that's the
correct thing as we spoke about
yesterday joe biden should do nothing to
encourage or interfere with an
investigation into hunter biden joe
biden should do nothing to interfere
with or encourage an investigation into
anything that donald trump has done but
the justice department is starting and
that's good news and it will likely mean
more legal fees for donald trump
i want to talk about a ridiculous
performance by pennsylvania republican
senate candidate mehmet oz and this is
the guy many know it as dr oz
we are
doing everything we can to just refer to
him as mehmet oz
because
saying dr oz almost it's like is useful
to him in some way
oz is running in pennsylvania as i
mentioned the leading democratic primary
opponent is a guy named john fetterman
who we're going to try to get on the
show very interesting candidate and
mehmet oz
apparently wanted to make the point that
groceries are expensive this is part of
the inflation story that republicans
have been telling but republicans don't
want to tell the story in good faith
there's been inflation gas prices are
high
but it's not joe biden's fault this is
happening globally but republicans want
to tell the story that it is joe biden's
fault so
what mehmet oz did
is make a very performative trip to a
local grocery store
and his point at the grocery store is
look how expensive it is to buy some
vegetables this is actually an
opportunity for memet oz to do something
useful at the grocery store but he
doesn't and i'm going to explain that in
a second let's first take a look at the
video i thought it was grocery shopping
i'm at weg nurse and my wife wants some
vegetables procrudite right so
here's a broccoli that's two bucks
without a ton of broccoli there
there's some asparagus that's four
dollars
yep
carrots
that's four more dollars that's ten
dollars of vegetables there and then we
need some guacamole that's four dollars
more
and
she loves salsa yeah salsa there
six dollars
must be a shortage of salsa guys that's
twenty dollars for kurute and this
doesn't include the tequila
i mean that's outrageous we got joe
biden to thank for this
okay
so he pick he makes a show by the way do
we believe he's really there shopping i
don't he makes a show of picking up a
two dollar piece of broccoli and a four
dollar asparagus and a four dollar it's
an enormous bag of carrots for four i
think it's a five pound bag uh four
dollar guacamole six dollar salsa so
it's twenty dollars for his crudite
ingredients so first of all salsa for
crudite no that's the first red flag
here that makes absolutely no sense
why are you getting salsa
for crudite but that's a culinary
critique but it exposes that this is
probably all bs but secondly
it's obviously super staged to make a
political point he's not out really
shopping for crudite to make for his
guests it's absurd it's like when mitt
romney went out to shop
and all he had in his cart was just
boxes and boxes of yogurt and i think
like seltzer it was really weird it
wasn't believable it was during his
presidential campaign but this is really
a missed opportunity instead of
complaining about prices
and buying things that don't even make
sense for the dish you claim to be
making as a doctor and here's where it
is relevant that he's a medical doctor
he should be explaining to people
how to more economically buy vegetables
which most americans aren't getting
enough of buying too many processed
foods now he's a doctor who's promoted
quack cures on his show
cures for colds that are completely
unproven all sorts of weird supplements
and different things and then when he
actually has an opportunity to talk
people in a real way about nutrition uh
he talks about inflation and tries to
blame joe biden he could have gone and
said hey you know what
instead of processed foods here's how
you can get real foods cheaply and make
them last this would be value if any
member of member of congress congress
did this republican or democrat i would
applaud them this is a big problem in
the united states people don't know
what's healthy they don't understand how
to economically have healthier foods uh
food products highly processed are
promoted to them he could go in and go
see this monstrous five pound bag of
carrots it's four bucks and that's a
good deal cut up some of the carrots get
hummus for three bucks that's a great
snack take some carrots and grate them
onto your salads to get more whatever i
don't remember i'm not a doctor is it
vitamin a whatever carrots have uh
carotene take some carrots put a little
avocado or olive oil or even canola oil
on them salt and pepper roast them now
you've got great sides for your lunches
instead of potato chips for the entire
week that's a great use of a five pound
bag of carrots
instead it's a confused guy claiming to
be making crudite with salsa
hey let me tell you about vegetables
that are the best value in the grocery
store we should all be doing more to eat
healthy get yourself sweet potatoes get
the bulk bag roast them alongside your
carrots keep them as a side dish for
breakfast get some eggs
toss
some cubed up already cooked sweet
potato
fry an egg
and then have a handful of blueberries
or you know whatever the case may be
these are
ideas to buy in larger quantities
don't have food waste and eat healthier
than a highly processed whatever it is
you know the granola bars or whatever it
is you're having for you know sugary
cereal whatever it's really a wasted
opportunity for a doctor
to really provide something of value and
show that he's the type of voice we
should be saying we need more of that in
the senate we need this is exactly what
we need more of in the senate he does
something cheap it adds nothing to the
conversation other than playing the same
political games that's mehmet oz running
in pennsylvania let me know your
thoughts find me on twitter at dpakman
we'll take a quick break what a friday
program we have for you today
one of our sponsors today is cheese
butter giving you 15
off i love this stuff cheese butter is a
delicious gourmet cheese melt that
ingeniously blends
four indulgent cheeses and aromatically
seasoned butter
all the ingredients the cheese the
butter the seasonings are sourced for
the highest quality you can really taste
that this was made with fresh simple
high shelf ingredients nothing
artificial
cheese on bread right i mean come on and
butter on bread why wouldn't i love
cheese butter put it on french bread
sourdough bagels english muffin jewish
rye pumpernickel
sandwiches grilled cheese burgers baked
potatoes mac and cheese broccoli veggies
cheese butter is a business that
supports the david pakman show support
them their product is really fantastic
it's been a secret recipe in their
family for 50 years
taste it for yourself to really
understand what it's about
i don't think you'll be sorry cheese
butter is giving my audience 15
off
when you go to
cheesebutter.com
pacman the david pakman show is of
course made possible by viewers like you
through our membership program listeners
like you you can sign up at
joinpackman.com it's quick it's easy
if you already have a membership you can
also now gift memberships by checking
the box that says
this is a gift funny enough
as you sign up and then we will give
your gift subscription to someone on our
waiting list currently uh 600 people
waiting for membership so it's a
beautiful number
let's hear from some people in the
audience we do these calls now via
discord you can find our discord at
davidpakman.com
discord
why don't we start today
um this is interesting let's start with
aaliyah from the faroe islands we've
never had a pharaoh islands caller
before aaliyah
you're on the air what's going on
no boy
aaliyah don't let us down
aaliyah from the pharaoh islands please
unmute and we'll be able to chat
well that's a shame that would have been
interesting let's go instead to brian
from phoenix brian from phoenix you're
on the air
hi david hey how are you
i am doing amazing uh i wanted to first
appreciate you flouting the pushback and
uh sticking with the an historic
pronunciation i think it's um oh boy
appreciate you're going going your own
way on that all right fair
um
i'm wondering if you believe uh in the
long term it would be a
uh
more beneficial uh more progressive
outcome to remove the filibuster
altogether
and uh sort of have the senate answer to
the voters for whatever legislation is
able to be passed in a in a 50 50 senate
or if you think that that would lead us
in the opposite direction in a in a less
progressive direction good question so
i here's my view on this
if i don't think about this
strategically
the filibuster doesn't make a lot of
sense to me the filibuster fundamentally
seems anti-democratic so if there were
no political considerations i would say
let's get rid of the filibuster
altogether
in practical terms i'm aware that if
democrats completely nuke the filibuster
at some point it'll come back to haunt
democrats and part of the reason why is
that the senate is fundamentally
anti-democratic and what i mean by that
is we have a hundred senators no matter
how many people live in any particular
state that's the state has two senators
and so there are senators that represent
millions and millions and millions of
people and there's senators that
represent i mean i don't know what the
wyoming population is now i think it's
like 700 000. so like each wyoming
senator in a sense represents 350 000
people which gives disproportionate
power
to
low population states which are
typically conservative so
i i don't love the filibuster i think it
doesn't make sense and i would be fine
getting rid of it if
we were to somehow fix the
anti-democratic nature of the senate
which doesn't seem like it's going to
happen anytime soon because that's the
way the system works
one semi-follow-up question very quick
would you support adding states for that
in the form of like splitting california
or i'm adding puerto rico i am open to
adding states but it would not be
specifically for that reason i think
that sometimes it would make sense that
there's a lot of pro i mean i think
puerto rico should be a state if it
wants to be um i think there are a
number of different arguments for
splitting up california but for me it's
more about does it make sense for for
economic reasons does it make sense for
other reasons not just as a political
strategy although as a political
strategy it would almost certainly help
democrats
awesome thanks david my pleasure that's
a that's a meaty phone call i like it
let's go next to austin from miami
austin from miami you're on the air
hi um i was just kind of wondering what
you think about what's gonna happen um
in midterm elections i mean i'm not
looking too much at like polls at this
point but just from my perception i feel
like democrats are getting a lot less
popular a lot of people you know are
blaming biden for the gas bill
or the gas prices and i just feel
like uh if they don't do anything about
it they're gonna stay very unpopular i
was wondering if you thought that they
were either aware of it or like what you
would recommend
i think democrats are aware of it so so
there's two sides to this austin the
first part of it is um
historically and and do if you can do
something to turn off the discord blings
that would be really great i don't know
if you're using push to talk or if you
haven't silenced notifications but i
would love your help with that so
on the one hand for historical reasons
typically when a party wins the white
house then the next midterms aren't good
for them so like historically speaking
democrats should should lose uh at least
control of the house or senate in
november on the other hand
we have this situation where in 2016 and
2020 you had a lot of trumpists voting
who never voted before trump they only
got involved in politics because of
trump and it remains an open question
whether uh there is going to be um a
sort of uh disappearance of many of
those individuals and they're not even
going to vote in november the other
question is we know covet has killed
more republicans than democrats to what
effect will the partisan death gap of
covid affect republicans so democrats
should be losing historically um joe
biden is also getting blamed for stuff
that's not his fault like gas prices
that's that those are not good things
for them but i think it's such a unique
midterm that it remains to be seen i
don't really have a prediction
yeah uh do you think that
though like
certain like i don't know do you think
do you see kind of the um new like
decriminalization of marijuana bill is
like something that they might be
putting forth to kind of
reclaim some popularity because i just
feel like from the perspective like they
have not really gotten anything done
with like the infrastructure bill being
gutted and they're not really doing
anything popular like as of right now or
making an effort to i think that time is
quite short and it would be really great
for democrats if they want to do well
to try to get something else major done
but to be perfectly frank it's not
seeming to me like they're going to be
able to do it so they're going to have
to run on convincing people based on
what's already happened um and that's
quite frankly it seems like that's going
to be a difficult thing to do
yeah i kind of just wish that they had
more control over uh you know getting
policies that are popular but obviously
there's a lot of uh i guess red tape
within the party yeah and there's also a
limited amount of political capital the
one thing i will say is
i don't really think joe biden has much
of an interest in doing student loan
forgiveness
but
he still could look at doing something
like that and maybe the new moratorium
on payments until august is him saying
well maybe in august i'll do some
student loan forgiveness which will help
us in november that was pat's idea on a
recent bonus show i don't know i don't
know but i think it's an interesting
question
yeah well thank you for your time i
definitely agree that biden should be
doing some kind of like emergency kind
of catch-up because i feel like he's
just catching a lot of flack for
inflation and gas and like i i i
obviously don't have like any like
concrete evidence on this but just from
like what i've seen living in like
florida i'm at the university of florida
but i'm from miami um just a lot of like
anti-biden sentiment let's go brandon is
everywhere you know i'm just a little
worried for the future you're right to
be worried austin thank you so much for
the call
let's go next to jamie from georgia
jamie uh welcome
hi thank you for welcoming me my
pleasure uh
yeah so um david what i wanted to what i
wanted to talk today about uh was the
was the rise of socialism in the us
according to this axios poll
apparently it's like a
uh 49 to 46 percent split between
favorably viewing
socialism and to capitalism i don't know
which way it is uh but either way what
are what are your thoughts on the rise
i have to tell you i don't know what
you're talking about so you're saying
the rise of
popularity are you saying yeah yeah like
yeah yeah like uh i'm sorry i didn't i
don't think i explained this very well
um i mean like the rise between
the rise of socialism being viewed in a
more favorable light compared to
capitalism being viewed in a very
positive light for instance during the
red scare
uh in the us socialism was viewed very
negatively compared to capitalism
okay i don't have the numbers in front
of me but i know that you're correct
that
socialism is seen less unfavorably in
the u.s now than it has been in a long
time so let's agree that that's going on
and and the specific numbers maybe maybe
we don't have in front of us
i don't have any particular hot take on
that um i mean listen here's what's
going on
the version of capitalism that exists in
the united states has failed many many
millions of people when we look at wages
when we look at access to just basics
that people need to live we have hunger
in the united states there's no reason
for that etc etc it's natural that
people would say wow this isn't working
what else is there and one of the other
things that there is in theory is
socialism so it's not shocking to me
given
the version of capitalism that exists
here that there would be people looking
for other things as far as socialism
goes i'm not personally a socialist that
doesn't mean anything in particular but
my point is i'm not like looking to
usher in socialism and socializing the
means of production and socialized
ownership of businesses i'm not looking
to do that i think
a lot of the people that now view
socialism more favorably
also aren't looking to do that and they
don't actually know what socialism is
uh so
that that's sort of my take not
surprising people are looking for
alternatives a lot of them don't really
know what socialism is a lot of the
people that claim to be socialists
aren't really like bernie says he's a
democratic socialist maybe he is but his
policy is one of social democracy which
is a regulated capitalism so i think
there's some confusion and there's some
logic to it as well
yes i i think that's a very good take uh
pac-man thank you uh
yeah i i will i will say
yes the the us in the u.s what is
considered socialism has largely been
incredibly stunted of course due to the
red scares and uber reactionaryism
that's fostered in the u.s uh culture
but um
would i i i think that a good way to
combat this would be to educate would be
to educate people on what socialism
really is sure and
yeah and i think and i and i would and i
will classify personally i would uh
classify demo uh social democracy is as
not a form of socialism but as sort of
like uh
sort of like a window into socialism
when people see that this little nugget
of socialism something that's barely
even socialism not even the economic
policies but just the everything else
policies of uh social democracy yeah i
think that people will be like hey so
this is just a nugget of socialism this
is really good if we have
this but on a much larger scale and in a
way that we make sure does not end up
like the soviet union or china then we
can have socialism and i think that
socialism will have even more of a boom
than it already is experiencing so i
don't agree with you personally i think
that having social democracy would lead
us towards being like the northern
european countries which are still
capitalist countries but what i will say
what you just said is the view of a lot
of incrementalist socialists so for
example i there's a streamer named ian
vausch and when i spoke to ian vausch he
said i'm a socialist but if we're ever
going to have socialism it's going to go
through social democracy so that people
realize hey this is the right direction
to go in so the view you're espousing
while it's not one i agree with is a
valid and uh widely held view among
actual socialists and i appreciate you
making that
point thank you
that's about all i had so
thank you for calling me david uh see
you see you next time all right we will
see you next time appreciate the call
uh let's go next to
uh why don't we go from donny from is it
pronounced visalia visalia
it's visalia visalia what state is that
in
it's in california oh beautiful
did i also not know where it was the
last time we spoke
yeah i probably should change it to
hillary county last time i mentioned
about that he went on uh trump
mentioning the
17th of our 1917 pandemic
uh
being with the connected
that's what i called last time beautiful
but what's on your mind today anyways
i was wondering what you what your
opinion was of adam schiff as for
president like uh i'm not sure if his
policies are really progressive or not
but i'm curious if you'd end if you
think he'd have any interest how do you
think he would do yeah so uh adam schiff
i find to be an uh interesting guy
a very smart great speaker not the most
progressive guy on the face of the earth
and he will bump up against
anti-semitism as a jewish gentleman
i think that if i were to look
in that direction i'd be more interested
in jamie raskin than adam schiff i think
jamie raskin is really a progressive
activist and so if you said schiffer or
raskin in thinking about the kind of
like
you know uh uh
jewish white guy uh with you know that
sort of profile i think i would lean
more raskin than schiff
yeah okay great
well that's all i had for you all right
beautiful short and sweet i appreciate
the call
uh let's see let's go next to
let's go to nug wrangler and the thing
about nug wrangler is nug wrangler is a
professional memer but nugs phone calls
are not at the same caliber as the memes
but i uh what's going on nug
hello
david okay
so i was reading a piece over
the american prospect a progressive news
magazine and there was a piece there
talking about
how profit rates should be included in
economic data not just wages
unemployment rate prices etc
what do you think about
this and how do you see things changing
if profits were actually studied and
included in economic data ah aren't they
in a way include so let me see if i can
think that through so you're saying okay
we have a lot of different ways of
measuring how an economy is doing we can
look at the unemployment rate we can
look at wages we can look at gdp we can
look at inflation consumer confidence
you're saying let's include corporate
profits in that
list of of metrics
uh yeah you know that way you could
gauge maybe if there's
profit gouging stuff like that the piece
i was reading was also talking about how
it's not really studied so it's
it's hard to
i guess use that
as a measurement even if it should be
somehow
i am always into having more information
rather than less i think you're on to
something which is
there what are we
it's a hard thing to calculate in the
sense that are we talking about the
average profit margin are we talking
about dollars is it weighted based on
company size i think if i knew a little
more about what exactly would be
measured i could give you a more
definite opinion about it but i'm always
for having more information rather than
less all those things mentioned
you know could be possible
definitely is an area of study that
should be looked into i agree with you
there should also be
some kind of measurement of how many how
many times people are
using their toilet
yeah i mean if it's if you have a
president
okay you're playing clips yeah listen if
you have a regime where people are
flushing 10 to 15 times
that can't possibly be as good as if
people are only flushing once i agree
with you
okay thank you thank you all right nug
wrangler with a better phone call than
normal i like it coming in with the with
the sound clips very very good
uh okay let's go next to jess in oregon
jess welcome
hello david
how are you
so
i'm just i'm just doing so wonderful i
we call i sorry i called um a few weeks
ago from florida from gainesville
florida right um and i've made my move
so now i'm here now are you in oregon or
oregon
i've nev i have been here about three
weeks and not heard one person call it
oregon so you can't say for sure but it
sounds like you're in oregon
yeah it's i think i'm i think that's
where eugene is is in oregon yeah
beautiful beautiful
so um i was wondering
i would love to get your take on
if this is a
good
potential middle ground
to um
pro-life and
pro-uh
pro-abortion rights so we there's have
you ever met a pro-abortion person i
never have pro-abortion to me means
you're going around trying to get people
to have abortions i've never seen that
right i said okay i should i should i
should uh pro-choice you pro-choice
abortion rights okay particularly okay
so if we're going if we're talking about
people who are for abortion rights and
people on the other side who think that
that is
murdering babies
you know it's kind of hard to find a
middle ground but see
i'm thinking of it like
why do we keep talking about that
particular aspect of abortion when there
are a lot of other aspects around this
that i think we can agree on like um
young mothers who
you know maybe would rather have
abortion if they can't get abortion then
um
you know add uh
add like federal funding for young
mothers
um to these bills
to these bills that that restrict um
abortion rights
absolutely yeah one of the things we've
talked about many times is
you can't both say
you should be forced to have a kid
and then not provide any support for the
kid to people
who are not financially in a good
position to have a kid
absolutely right because yeah um you
know if the if the other solution is
get rid of the kid before it's born and
you can't do that okay well then help me
out if i'm forced to have a kid you know
yeah this is the broader this is the
broader hypocrisy
of
an insane amount of concern for you know
clumps of cells four weeks into a
pregnancy and then total disregard for
babies after they're born that that's a
long-term hypocrisy we've seen
but see instead of like i i know you and
i and many other people
who share that same view
we kind of get stuck on like oh you
pro-life people are being so
hypocritical instead
be like hey pro-life people what about
this idea do you agree with this sure no
it should be proposed absolutely the
problem is most in most cases
if democrats try to bring that up during
a debate over abortion republicans would
say that's not this bill if you want to
propose a different bill propose it but
right now we're talking about this bill
so that's the political strategy
question you have to deal with
really yeah so they think that that's a
different
situation really well they would say
it's not part of republicans would say
that's just not part of our bill if you
want to propose that propose it but
you've got to make your own bill
uh-huh because because restricting
abortion isn't a direct cause to that
effect oh of course you're right about
it
you're not wrong that it's of course
related okay all right jess thank you
for the call i appreciate it um
what i'm saying is the republicans
wouldn't allow it into their bill they
would say here's what we want to do
about abortion here's what's right to do
about abortion if you have other ideas
that you want to propose by all means go
ahead and propose them
let's take a very quick break if you're
holding just keep holding because we're
going right back to the phones in a
moment
let's go back to the phones and by
phones i mean discord it's not really
phones but for some reason we keep
calling them phones i guess they are
calls they're discord calls
davidpakman.com
discord
let's go where are we going to go next
because it's just it's crazy what's
happening on the discord lines today
let's try
alex from
spokane or spokane washington you're on
the air
hi david how are you doing i'm doing
well
um so
i wanted to touch on this topic um given
the democratic leadership you have steny
hoyer and jim clyburn and there tends to
be this conventional wisdom that
progressive democrats can only win in
districts like ayanna presley's um and
that if we were to turn the democratic
party toward that more progressive
direction
that we would knew that we would lose
nationwide and there is a piece on
jacobin about this
given the fact that rural voters have
really turned toward the republican
party
and the reality is that in 2022
i have seen a candidate that has run a
totally grassroots
grassroots-people-powered
congressional bid
and that's derek marshall he's running
in the 23rd congressional district
down in the high desert of southern
california
and i was just curious if you've been
keeping tabs on the midterms and if
there's any candidates
that have like struck your eye as
candidates running in rural areas places
that are maybe unconventional so that we
can continue to
uh fight for issues that are affecting
people who are maybe most
disproportionately affected by poverty
and by the day-to-day struggle i i can't
say specifically that there's
progressive rural candidates that i
would be able to sort of like recommend
to anybody but my recommendation would
be
if you are in a rural area
find out who's running because my
capacity on the show to know about every
candidate running everywhere is is very
limited and my ability to interview all
of them is also very limited but
uh we're going to have very soon i was
interviewed by farron cousins in las
vegas recently and he's going to be
publishing an interview we did
sort of about exactly this issue which
is how do you deal with figuring out
what races to get involved in and i'm
going to be talking about it on the show
as well uh but but you know
unfortunately it's beyond the scope of
my show to tell everybody who to support
etc etc
but there's no shortage of great
candidates out there and it's great that
you're paying attention
i'm thinking
all right there uh there we go very very
important message for sure
let's go next where are we where are we
going next here what about um i don't
know how about billy from jersey billy
you're on the air
hey david
can you hear me i can hear you fine
billy okay quick question please can you
describe to me what a woman is
i'm kidding
actually my question is
you think of somebody who's radical in
behavior
it's somebody who may be erratic
how would you describe a radical type of
a person
is it an erratic radical
like
decisions they make and things they do
because at a trump rally
come out
as a former president will say
a radical
do nothing democrats
in the same sentence
right
which means
they're
all over the place but they're also
doing completely nothing
billy there's a crazy squealing in the
background and it sounds like you got a
tv on and it sounds like you're on
speaker is there can you can you help us
out here so we're on the same team
rather than on opposite teams
sorry um
let me see um
so billy tell me is this like a word
game or a political question i'm trying
to figure out are we just playing games
with the words erratic and radical or
what's going on
oh um
just
it's it's when you call somebody a
radical oh boy
all right billy i'm gonna let you go wow
it's crazy what's happening over at
billy's place it's it's really it's
quite a scene like it's hard to even
keep up with all of it let's go to mike
in northeastern connecticut mike you're
on the air
david thank you for picking my call i
had a question about ranked choice
voting okay and why massachusetts didn't
uh pass that in the last vote
did that not pass in massachusetts i
don't remember there's so many ballot
initiatives i can't remember all of them
i don't know why it didn't pass if
that's the case but i've spoken about
ranked choice voting a number of times
there's a number of different
configurations of it single transferable
vote and many others i think the most
important thing when it comes to ranked
choice voting is voters need to be
confident that there is no possible way
that someone who really doesn't have a
plurality of voters
wanting them to be the winner uh ends up
as the winner and uh it's sort of like a
mathematical problem and we've done a
number of interviews on this there's a
number of systems that ensure that and
that accomplish that
and it's generally speaking a system i'm
in favor of with the caveat that i would
like to see rank choice voting
and
um a public financing of elections and
campaign finance reform because not only
is it important to generate votes for
third parties and additional parties it
would also be great for the main two
parties not to have such an overwhelming
advantage when it comes to the money so
i think you need to do both together i'd
also love to see a national popular vote
um and uh all of these things together
feel like pipe dreams but they're the
ideal that that i've sort of envisioned
now do you feel the voters would be
competent enough to fill out anything
more than a regular ballot i don't know
i mean we we do have a competence in
education problem in the united states
i'm pretty confident
that if people just get a piece of paper
and it says there are five candidates
rank them one to five that most voters
would be able to do that correctly i'm
i'm modestly confident in that
okay great and uh do you ever touch on
the right to repair that was another
massachusetts uh
ballot initiative i'm generally speaking
in favor of the right to repair i've
heard the arguments that right to repair
would
allow people to get vehicles fixed
uh or devices fixed by
people who aren't really qualified but i
don't really buy that i think you can
deal with the qualification and the
certification so my view is it's
basically a way to monopolize um uh uh
service and repair dollars and i'm in
favor of right to repair
great thank you for taking my call my
pleasure mike from um northeastern
connecticut
a lot of interesting stuff there
let's go next to jude from baltimore hey
jude oh my god
hey what's going on david um so
today i have a question i have two
questions if that's all right sure so my
first question is actually you know you
mentioned that we could be losing the
house and or the senate in these uh
midterm elections coming up so
what is the best piece of legislation or
the best thing we could see
uh before we possibly lose power in
november
so there's two different questions here
there's what would be the most impactful
to the country and what might get
democrats the most votes on the latter
i continue to think
that um
some student significant student loan
forgiveness and remember joe biden can't
just forgive all student loans the best
legal opinions i've read are that that
that would need to go through congress
that's my understanding um
but but significant student loan
forgiveness
uh i think would get a lot of votes for
democrats in november
when i when if you're asking me what do
i think is the one thing that would be
most impactful to the country it's the
the typical big issues everybody talks
about wholesale campaign finance reform
health care for all
serious climate change uh
regulations and legislation but those
are not necessarily the things that
would be most popular with voters
yeah i agree i think that a lot of
people what they see
they they think of maybe one or two
issues that they're really passionate
about and they don't take into account
the entire um
like focus of things so i'm a uh
a student myself um i go to the
university of maryland baltimore county
okay um and yeah so i'm uh i'm an
environmental engineering major like
chemical engineering environmental track
so i care about climate change but that
doesn't stop me from you know thinking
about other issues that are also
important and i think a lot of people
got to do that would you agree
absolutely
yeah and then my second question is do
we still care about vaccine hesitancy is
it still a very big problem because
we're getting to the point now where
it's been 20 what is it 25 months since
kovid first really hit yeah and you know
we still have you know i don't know good
statistics but at least a quarter of you
know african americans or black people
not wanting to take the vaccine and at
least i don't know some maybe 20 or
somewhere in the teens for white people
so are we still concerned about those uh
people not getting the vaccine are they
still hurting us or yeah are we so far
away from it that it's like
why is it's not even that big an issue
anymore i don't know the numbers that
you just stated but there's a ton of
people that still refuse to get
vaccinated here's my thought on that at
this stage of the pandemic
the vaccination becomes increasingly an
individual decision there's still some
data that the degree to which
unvaccinated people spread the disease
is higher but it's not like the be all
end-all where we say oh if you're
vaccinated you you don't spread it no if
you're vaccinated you get much less
seriously ill
so
we're a little less concerned about the
vaccine refusers for that reason the
problem is
the vast majority of the vaccine refusal
is based on incorrect beliefs and
usually when people are vaccine refusers
they also believe a lot of other crazy
stuff so we care about it because it's
part of this
kind of uh um culture of ignorance and
people who don't accept science and that
type of thing
yeah i agree it's like that it's like
that part of like ideology where people
think that you know grass is blue and
then they vote for donald trump right
you know that that's how we get people
in the white house like that that's
exactly right yeah yeah exactly on my
campus uh we have to wear a mask only
when we're inside classrooms but not
when we're inside buildings or at the
gym or you know at places so it's
interesting to me because i'm thinking
okay well you know obviously there's
still a problem anyhow we need to wear a
mask but we don't really have to wear it
so what's the point of these rules and
it's been two years so it's just kind of
jumbling it's not a totally coherent
strategy i i totally totally agree with
that jude thank you so much for the call
i appreciate it
all right there's jude oh sorry uh jude
was saying one last thing there but i i
i cut off jude i apologize for that
thank you to everyone who called in
sorry if i didn't get to you we will
take calls again
it's time for the friday mailbag let's
get to it if you have something to say
hopefully something substantive
hopefully something relevant to the
audience hopefully something related to
things that have actually been said on
the show unlike many of the emails i get
you can email info davidpakman.com
don't abuse it don't send too many
emails or you'll get blocked we'll start
today with this is a little bonus this
one is actually from facebook i'm sorry
this one's from youtube this is from rob
rob who says dave packman hates
the god bless
the usa what a loser now
this could mean one of two things and
this relates to the i've told you guys
that something about trump rallies in
2022 is really triggering to the
trumpists i would cover trump rallies in
2017 uh in 2016 i would cover trump
rallies leading up to the 2020 election
even in 2021 those weird trump rallies
the trumpists didn't really care about
my coverage they didn't seem triggered
by it in 2022 every time i cover a trump
rally live i get a deluge of youtube
comments twitter replies and emails from
people furious with my coverage now this
could mean one of two things
rob might mean
that i hate the usa which of course i
don't
or
rob might mean i hate that terrible
country song that trump plays at every
rally
that ends god bless the usa or starts
that way or is called that i don't even
really know it's i don't like the song
so it could mean one of two things i
don't know which it is
but uh i appreciate hearing from rob as
always
jeff wrote to me this is fascinating
jeff is a former trump supporter
and jeff wrote to me and said
mr pacman with great respect
i voted for donald trump twice
i was a moderate republican with left
social views
and i didn't realize just how much q
anon had infiltrated the party until
january 6th as a result of that and i
really like kirsten cinema and jared
polis
i will be voting with the democrats
until this rot has been removed
i'm worried about democrats and
independents not voting this fall
because they might be mad about
inflation and other issues what can i as
a betrayed trump supporter do to help
get the anti-trump vote out in 22 and 24
phone bank phone bank phone bank phone
bank for any candidate that you believe
uh is uh a sort of sort of a swing
district an important seat in 2022. jeff
also said i figured out about trump's
demagoguery on my own but your show has
helped me become more comfortable with
the left thank you jeff this is a
beautiful email great to hear from jeff
about this issue
and um this is you know this is a
reminder
this stuff matters
people listen to this and and we we do
have an impact it is great to hear now i
know a lot of you will focus in on as
you can see here
where
jeff says he likes kirsten cinema and i
know my progressive audience really
doesn't like kirsten cinema don't focus
on that focus on the fact that this is
someone who voted for trump twice who
now is not voting for republicans that's
still a good thing
next email is from ray ray this one's
actually from uh this one's actually
from youtube
ray ray said david says he doesn't care
about bible quotations and then quotes
the bible and gives passage location as
a jew david has not followed king david
and yielded his will to yahweh he has
rejected messiah and the propitiation
offered by jesus as a blood sacrifice
for sin he is a child of wrath and
unredeemed a rebel against yahweh and
one of them a lawyer asking him a
question testing him teacher what is the
great commandment in the law and he said
you shall love the lord your god with
all your heart and with all your soul
and with all your mind
this is the great and foremost
commandment okay this is
out of control crazy but the one part i
want to address is
do people understand that
when i say
i don't care about the bible
but for people who do here is what it
says
that is i think clear to most people and
the context was madison cawthorne
madison cawthorne
had wrongly quoted the bible and what i
said was
i don't care what the bible says one way
or the other
i don't care
but madison cawthorn claims to care
and his followers claim to care so for
the people that do care
here's what the bible actually says it
you guys understand that right that's
not that's not a double standard
ray ray you got to get it together my
friend
brandon wrote in about accountability
and brandon wrote
david i was wondering
why are congress members allowed to lie
without consequence all the time
is there a way to hold them accountable
for these lies such as a policy that
makes them come clean after proven to be
wrong to me that just seems like a
normal courtesy of everyday people
thanks for your thoughts yeah i mean
listen brandon's not wrong it would be
great if more elected officials did what
i do on the show which is when i know
i've gotten something wrong not buried
on the bonus show at the top of the show
i will say guys i got something wrong
yesterday gals i have to make a
correction
um but anything beyond that
actually could potentially violate the
first amendment
um
so i'm not i'm not sure exactly what you
have in mind brandon but as a show of
common decency
it would be great for elected officials
not to lie as much and when they get
things wrong
to correct them as quickly as possible
lauren rhoden about trans rights and
critical race theory
lauren said good evening david
this question may be a bit ignorant and
i've tried to reap read up on it without
a veil my question is
is trans rights part of critical race
theory or are these two different issues
i assumed critical race theory was
solely race related but i hear all of
these people associating them as the
same issue
i appreciate your perspective thank you
for being a logical voice in this
illogical world so lauren let me give
you two answers the first answer is
everything can be related
any fight
against injustice can be related and to
the extent that supporters of critical
race theory and supporters of trans
rights believe that both are frameworks
for giving people rights and
it all could be related so i know that
if i just say
these are two different issues
someone will say
david sir or they might be less polite
you're being discriminatory by claiming
that these are unrelated issues now my
opinion is these are unrelated issues so
you can always find some thread to link
things together you can link together
you know uh mandarin oranges and uh
you know nuclear energy i don't know i'm
sure you could
but but these really are two separate
things critical race theory is a subset
of critical theory critical theory
a great framework for understanding
literature uh a great framework from the
mid-20th century for thinking about a
lot of different things
and critical race theory specifically
wants to apply that to our understanding
of race in society
and
different people have different opinions
on it
i'm not like big on critical race theory
critical theory i i find fascinating
post-modernism i find fascinating okay
etc fine so that's critical race theory
uh trans rights
is about trans rights and it relates to
equality under the law it relates to the
bathroom stuff there's the sports
element of it
there's who can sue for gender
discrimination and that came up during
the um katanji brown jackson hearings so
again
with the idea that crt concerns itself
with
rights along race
and trans rights relates to trans rights
you could say there's some threat there
but yes you're not wrong lauren that
these there are two separate issues here
swint wrote in about social security and
medicare bankruptcy swint says mr pakman
sir i've been told many times by many
people that medicare and social security
are going bankrupt on your show today
you mentioned this is not true can you
please elaborate on this so i understand
better okay so there's a difference
between going bankrupt
and headed towards insolvency
bankruptcy is
that's it you're out of business you
can't pay medicare being bankrupt means
they can't pay for anybody's health
health care
uh social security being bankrupt means
there's no more social security benefits
for anybody
if nothing is done
um
with cost of living
growing and baby boomers retiring
social security could get to the point
where if nothing changes they wouldn't
be able to pay their full benefits to
everybody okay so what does that mean
you have to do well there's a couple
different ways you could do it you could
reduce benefits
uh you could make people wait longer to
retire
or you could collect more money and one
of the simplest ways you can fix social
security's insolvency that would
eventually come and eventually
is you raise the cap on which social
security tax is collected right now
you only pay social security tax on
roughly your first 130 ish thousand
dollars so if you make two hundred
thousand dollars a year that last 70k
you're not paying into social security
at all if you make a million dollars a
year
you that last 870 k you're not paying
into social security so there's some
really small tweaks that could be made
to fix the insolvency issue similarly
with medicare
uh with health care costs rising baby
boomers retiring etc if nothing has
changed medicare could become insolvent
which means it would have a it would
have a budget crunch not bankruptcy
really important to understand not a
subtle difference
jim wrote in about the will smith
smack
and said do you think the right wing is
upset about will smith because they're
confusing chris rock for kidrock as
as funny as that is jim and have not
heard that before
i actually don't think that's the
confusion but i love the i love the idea
very very clever and lastly patrick
wrote in and patrick says question
watch your show sometimes curious when
are you going to discuss
hunter biden's laptop like to hear your
comments
we will talk about hunter biden's laptop
when there's really something to talk
about there is an investigation into
hunter biden's business dealings they
don't relate to the laptop
and i already covered it that's really
the story and hunter biden has nothing
to do with the biden administration so
there's not too much to say about it but
if there's something to cover about
hunter's biden's laptop and if hunter
biden becomes relevant to what's going
on politically
joe biden something something relevant
be sure that i will be covering it my
friend no question about it that's going
to do it for today we have a tremendous
bonus show coming up for you become a
member sign up at joinpakman.com and
remember if you already have a
membership
you can now gift memberships to others
just go through the sign up process
check the box that says this is a gift
we have 600 people waiting for
memberships who have requested
memberships
uh
make someone's dream come true gift a
membership at joinpacman.com i'll see
you on the bonus show
cheese butter is the delicious gourmet
cheese melt that blends four indulgent
cheeses and seasoned butter i love this
stuff perfect on bread bagels sandwiches
veggies and more you'll get 15
off at cheesebutter.com
pacman the link is down below